-Today was World Water Day,
so shout-out to my hose!
Scollins.
Ruins World Water Day.
And, you know,
he thinks he's very clever,
but, uh, I saw
how you spelled the joke.
Today was
National Agriculture Day,
so shout-out to my hoes!
Scollins again.
Back-to-back days.
Turns in the same joke.
And finally, today was
National Cheesesteak Day.
Celebrate by taking a Whiz.
Three days in a row
from Scollins.
A Turkey.
We gotta say -- I mean, again,
I think if you're
one of our loyal viewers,
Mike Scollins, for three days in
a row, has written a joke
about whatever
national day it was.
And now, you have to
tune in tomorrow
to see if he can get
four in a row.
The rare Hambone,
I believe it's called.
So, hopefully for Scollins,
tomorrow is
National Hacky Joke Day.
And finally, today was --
Ooh, actually,
before I tell this joke --
There's a lot of national days
on the calendar.
Pretty much every day
in the set-ups of our jokes,
you find out
what national day it is.
And something that's never
been attempted before
has happened this week.
Mike Scollins, a writer
for the show, has told
a "today was national
whatever day"
with a punch line
three days in a row,
which is known as a Turkey.
No one's ever done
four in a row,
but he's about to try,
and we're about to see if he can
tell four funny jokes
about a national day
of the week.
For those who don't know,
this is our friend
Mike Scollins right here.
Let's just show him off.
There you go.
[ Laughter ]
That's Mike
in his every-day outfit.
And now,
we're gonna find out...
if he can
"tank-top" himself.
[ Laughs ]
And finally,
today was Pecan Day.
Well, I hope you got a nut.
Judges?
[ Pins clattering ]
Ahh.
Heartbreaking.
[ Laughs ]